- [Voiceover] It's tournament time.
Some college basketball players do unique
things to get ready for a big game.
(upbeat rap music)
- [Troy Caupin] On game day, no matter
how much time there is, I always lay down
a little bit to get my mind right.
- [Mike Gesell] I eat the same thing so,
it's chicken, some corn,
some broccoli, a baked potato
and I finish it off with some pancakes.
- [Zack Auguste] My pregame ritual song
is to listen to "March Madness" by Future.
♫ I'm the one that's living lavish
- Because it gets me ready to go battle.
- [Austin Burgett] I have a
handshakes with some of the managers.
I always have to do 'em before
the game to make sure
everything's balanced.
- [Vince Edwards] I always tape my wrists
and uh, very superstitious about that.
Having my son's initials on there,
you have something to play for,
you have a meaning to it
and great feeling to
look down and see that.
- [Riley Lachance] I always put
my left sock on before my right.
It's just something I've always done.
- [Kevin Johnson] When I enter the court,
I always warm up on the
right side of the court.
- [Marcus Paige] Yeah, I
don't share my secrets.
Shhh.
(clicking)
(upbeat rap music)